and we do thank you for joining us on
this friday night at 11 on 8 news now
i'm brian loftis concerning words from
the white house today
as its covid19 team lists las vegas
as the worst large city in the nation
for the virus and virus transmission
local health officials also recommending
mask wearing for
everyone as case numbers and
hospitalizations sort of levels not seen
since back in february this is our city
gets ready for another jam-packed
weekend of a lot of entertainment
sasha loftis joining us from the las
vegas strip to see what precautions
people might be taking
as you can see the strip is packed this
friday night
we spoke with some who say these rising
coveted 19 numbers
don't bother them while others say it's
making them reconsider some of their
plans
everything is pretty crowded after
months of shutdowns and restrictions
vegas is still roaring back to life
casinos have ditched capacity limits
concerts and sports venues are packed
with people
but few are wearing masks and experts
call our latest covid19 trends
concerning this is becoming a pandemic
of the unvaccinated the cdc sounded the
alarm
friday while the southern nevada health
district recommended
everyone wear face coverings indoors
again
regardless of vaccination status and as
our state positivity rate climbs to 11.3
percent
the white house kovid 19 team also cited
the las vegas metro area
as the worst in the nation for virus
transmission
got it twice and don't know how and when
and why but
some we spoke with say this news won't
change their plans
you know i guess we're willing to take
that risk to have a good time while
others encourage
everyone to get vaccinated get a shot or
wear a mask
so we can stay open and get this search
under control it's sad that we're in
this state having to deal with it
some casinos here on the las vegas strip
have reinstated mass mandates for
employees
regardless of vaccination status now we
do have a 46 percent
vaccination rate that's those fully
vaccinated who are eligible here in
nevada
and that is below the national average
reporting on the las vegas strip tonight
sasha loftis
8 news now